my name is Hank Reid and this is a
message to the graduating class of 2009
have a pinata hit it any school middle
school high school college and graduate
school I'm graduated five times so I'm a
bit of an expert on the subject so no
matter what you just graduated from you
are about to go change the world you
have a lot more learning to do we
welcome you with open arms into the real
world graduation speeches they all sound
like this I think mostly what I want to
say is do not trust anyone who is
telling you the way the world is going
to be for you I graduated from college
with a major in biochemistry and now I'm
professional Internet let's be
honest with ourselves here
things are changing rather quickly the
advantage that you have is not all the
stuff you just learned you need that
don't get me wrong but everybody else
has it too the advantage that you have
is a whole new world just got discovered
and you grew up there I'm in my 20s
people my age do not understand the
world the way you do it's like there was
a first generation for you who are born
in America you're like that except
you're the first generation of people
who were born on the internet don't ask
me how your mom did that but she did and
it is not just that you know how to
utilize this stuff Oh Timmy knows what
Facebook is she hangs out on 4chan and
discusses memes and that is how you
should try and convey it to your elders
but that is not your actual advantage
more than a conception of how it works
you have a completely different
perception of how the world works the
days when people could be satisfied
being the expert in a mere one field are
over my friends you all and I think you
know this are going to have to be the
men and women of the new Renaissance new
Renaissance men and women be ready to do
everything and when no one asks you to
do it for them be ready to do it for
yourself so that's where you're at now
friends
I suggest you enjoy it